hola bienvenidos a economía en france 24
me acompaña en el estudio daniela
blandón hola daniela comenzamos hablando
de champagne y esa guerra que ha
comenzado entre francia y rusia por este
producto que lo que pasa hola santiago
cómo está mire para los conocedores como
usted y usted me corregirá un vino
espumoso puede llamarse champagne solo
si proviene de la región de francia que
tiene ese mismo nombre y si se elabora
bajo ciertas regulaciones de hecho la
palabra tiene protección legal en unos
120 países pero una nueva ley firmada
por el presidente ruso vladimir putin
dice que en ese país sólo puede usarse
la palabra champán para el vino local y
que los franceses que vendan allí deben
conformarse con usar el término vino
espumoso y en la parte posterior de la
etiqueta la polémica ya va en un lío
diplomático con el gobierno francés
advirtiendo que llevaría el caso a la
organización mundial del comercio
una vez que hayamos considerado todas
las limitaciones que representan la
legislación rusa actuaremos en los
próximos días a través de relaciones
naturales pero también a nivel europeo
para defender los intereses de nuestros
sectores especialmente los intereses de
nuestras denominaciones de origen
esperamos poder resolverlo y ciertas
particulares el diálogo lo que estamos
diciendo es tome su champagne traiga lo
a nuestro país llévelo a un laboratorio
y el laboratorio verificará si aplica
con los estándares de vino espumoso o no
va a ser una larga disputa entre francia
y rusia daniel hablemos ahora de la
clase media de perú que cayó en 2020 por
culpa pues como sabemos de la pandemia
del cob y 19 claro santiago hay un
estudio de la cámara de comercio de lima
que explica que una familia de cuatro
miembros el considerado de clase media
cuando sus ingresos mensuales oscilan
entre 2.150 y 10 mil 750 soles esto es
entre 562 mil 795 dólares a precio de
hoy en 2019 antes de la crisis estaban
en este grupo unos 14 millones de
personas
o sea el 43 6% de la población y calcula
la cámara de comercio que en 2020 apenas
el 24 por ciento quedó clasificado como
clase media esto significa que la
pandemia pudo haber dejado unos 63
millones de peruanos por fuera de este
grupo social
daniela esto es preocupante naciones
unidas advirtió sobre una posible
hambruna en mozambique y una ex colonia
portuguesa en el este de áfrica bueno
pues el grupo o por lo menos el
conflicto armado protagonizado por
extremistas islámico en la provincia
norteña de cabo delgado comenzó en 2017
y ha dejado al menos 700 30.000
desplazados en los próximos meses el
programa mundial de alimentos de
naciones unidas espera que al menos la
mitad entré en una situación grave de
inseguridad alimentaria y si no
recibimos apoyo financiero inmediato lo
más probable es que nos veamos obligados
a recortar la asistencia alimentaria o
suspenderla por completo ya que
necesitamos 121 millones de dólares para
ayudar a 730 mil personas entre
septiembre y diciembre
el gobierno de eeuu canceló un
millonario contrato con microsoft
cuántos millones de muchísimos
diez mil millones de dólares
aproximadamente y miré la historia a
finales de octubre de 2017 el
departamento de defensa de eeuu adjudicó
un contrato microsoft valorado hoy en
esa cifra de 10 mil millones de dólares
para almacenar datos en la nube y
aprovechar la tecnología en sus
estrategias de defensa
desde ese momento amazon inició una
batalla legal en tribunales contra el
gobierno porque atribuyó la adjudicación
a razones políticas del entonces
presidente de donald trump y no a una
competencia en particular por el
antagonismo entre trump y el fundador de
amazon jeff bezos él a su vez es dueño
del 'washington post' un periódico muy
criticado por el exmandatario pues el
pentágono anunció sorpresivamente que
reinará el proceso o reiniciará mejor
para que tanto amazon como microsoft
puedan participar aunque sólo esas dos
porque dice que ninguna otra cumple con
los requisitos para el contrato más
grande de este departamento en el ámbito
tecnológico indicadores daniela como le
fue a las principales
termino una racha de siete días en
positivo para wall street en medio del
inicio de una turbulenta semana para los
precios del petróleo pues a propósito de
esto en latinoamérica el mismo petróleo
hizo caer las bolsas también al menos la
de sao paulo santiago y mexico
gracias daniela por esta información
actualización de los principales hechos
económicos es todo por el momento aquí
en france 24 siga con nosotros
[Música]